Bán nhân dân thành phó hà nội, buộc phê duyệt kế hệ bảo nằm thất nước, trong 1 ngập khu vực nội thành thành phố 1 mua năm 2020.
Chên cơ sở tổng hợp thống kê biệm uống gập của 1 trong 20 xa và các đơn vị duy trí thân nước.
Sở xe dựng vự báo tình như 1 ngập trong 1 mua năm 2020, các cậm hệ sở theo các kịch bản tương ứng với lượng người như sau.
Với các trận 1 giới 50 mili mẹ một dờ thành phố không xảy ra uống gập.
Cơ bản chỉ tôn tải 1 vài vị trí ở động nước.
Gió cáo đổ mặt đường trụng thất, khoa hệ thống thất nước gập sự cố, các trận 1 tuy năm 2020,
hí li mẹ một dờ thành phố tổng tải 1 mua điểm uống gập ở các phường xảy.
Các trận 1 tuy bẩy 1 đế một trăm 1 li mẹ một dờ thành phố dự báo có bẩy 1 diểm uống gập của bộ tại 3 mi xảy phường.
Trong đó xong mi tư điểm thuật các phường và bây điểm ở các xảy.
Với các trận 1 đặc biệt lớn trên 1 trăm 1 li mẹ một dờ trở lên trong nhiều dờ.
Hành phố có 2 trăm 2 mi điểm uống gập của bộ thuật 5 tuy phường xả,
trong đó 1 trăm 3 mi tám điểm ở 3 mi năm phường và 1 mi 2 điểm ở Mỹ chính xả.
Thành phố đặc biệt lúc đưa nước nhận về các môn tiêu và trả 1 đồng mối.
Bà đàn thất nước nhành với trận 1 kỳ cơm độ 18,5 mi lế mẹ trên 2 ngày.
Tại khu vực đã được cải tạo theo dõi án thống nước hà nội.
Giang thiều điểm uống gập của bộ.
Dạy pháp trung để ứng phó gồm tăng cường công thất giữ báo khảnh báo,
xây dựng kịch bản và các tình bộ của thệ rui chỉ dần suyên hệ thống gống giảng thác nước mưa xong hồ đi qua.